[Music]
yeah so superstar usa was a reality show
they basically cloned american idol i
think it was in 2004
um they cloned american idol but instead
of looking for the nation's best singer
their goal was to find the nation's
worst singer but make them think like
they're the best
that's a good idea yeah so like they
they basically pranked them for an
entire season
nationally syndicated reality show it
was as big as american idol i [ __ ]
watched it every week they made these
people truly believe that they were
really good singers and at the very end
it goes way deeper than that it's like
they gave them
uh they met them they let them meet with
like one of the best
vocal coaches they uh got their
makeovers they took them house shopping
so that when they're superstars after
the show they know like what type of
house and like mansion and car they want
to buy the very last episode
was the only episode that they
did in front of an actual live studio
audience because the rest of the show
they couldn't figure out how to to make
the audience be in on it because it's
such like a [ __ ] up concept that the
audience would definitely ruin it the
very last episode the finale the way
they did that is by telling
the audience that these were make-a-wish
kids and that it was their wish
to sing like on a show like this like on
an american idol type show
because and like these people are
genuinely like the worst singers
i've ever heard in my entire life is
there a positive in here somewhere or do
they all just end up blowing their
brains out that i don't i like googled
them afterwards because we did a video
on it and i googled it afterwards to see
if i could find like what the winner is
doing now
and i couldn't find it she like has kids
somewhere and i think she's fine but
like
i mean
i i can't even imagine i mean that like
the the five years of her life after she
was done with that show must have been
complete hell
like imagine going back to your small
ass town knowing you just got like
humiliated for
months
in front of the entire country yeah you
got dunked on picturing like the
boardroom in that moment being like
yeah we should do this dude it's the guy
that made the [ __ ] bachelor oh
ryan seacrest no what he didn't make the
passer
oh well he made a i want to marry harry
and that's just as bad so that is so
this is the winner
dark bro [ __ ] it's [ __ ] up dude
okay listen i'm not trying to stereotype
anybody but when you hear make a wish
kid
is this what you think
i don't know much about make-a-wish
children but i believe they're in a very
precarious state of being and i just
don't know if running around singing is
i'm just saying as an audience member
wouldn't your [ __ ] meter go off at
some point like wait a second
well yeah it gets super awkward at the
end because the announcer like the host
tells her what the point of the show was
like in front of the audience and the
audience is super confused so like
nobody is really like they don't know
what to do he's basically like we were
trying to find america's worst singer
and you won and she's like what
and the whole audience is like uh
because they got duped too so they're
like what the [ __ ] is going on so we've
been doing black mirror stuff since 2004
is what you're saying the early 2000s
were super black mirror like do you
remember the black swan remember that no
dude they basically the whole point of
the show was to take you know like ugly
people and give them tons of plastic
surgery
until the point where they're like quote
unquote hot and i'm talking lipo i'm
talking like implants uh like dental
procedures face reconstruction
everything that was the show and they
did a reveal at the end they had them
work with like a like a life coach like
all and then like it's basically they're
i
it's students so [ __ ] dark man
irreversible changes
oh my god maybe pull up i don't even
want to watch a clip with that actually
it's [ __ ] crazy i'm looking for it
are you sure it's called black swan
black swan yes no sorry it's called the
swan
swan got it
yeah black swan is with julia roberts
yeah yeah that's a that's a movie sorry
wait was it no it was natalie portman
yeah yeah
oh hell yeah oh and they got an english
person hosting it oh even better no no
wait let's let's go the first 15 seconds
let's hear this
uh you can really run it
four minutes is kind of long but yeah
let's rip i mean we could just do a
little reaction right now because it's
claiming that she wanted to be invisible
dr annie do you think she's still going
to want to hide from the outside world
when marsha got here she was extremely
socially anxious very isolated but she's
worked hard in therapy and i think she
knows now that not only does she deserve
to be respected but she's yo pause toss
this therapist
just violating
all
of being yeah all principles of being a
therapist like you know a therapist is
supposed to teach you to be you know
emotionally strong and believe in
yourself and she's like you should
definitely change your face it's [ __ ]
up she's she was ugly as [ __ ] but now i
think she's completely gonna slay
all her new work is serving
bro what was your plan to bring out her
beauty i think marsha felt invisible
because she really couldn't get a good
feel for her features so the idea was to
make her more distinctive just really
bring out her inner beauty i feel
completely unbearably disgusted with
myself bro positive it makes me feel
i
i don't i mean just at present i don't
see a ton of need to get all hacked up
under the knife like
maybe just
some makeup i don't know
yeah i agree i mean
makeup and hair color maybe and then
just like
don't
like let her wear boot cut jeans anymore
really unfeminine to have she really had
to show her shaving her chance that is
so
that is biggest
it's probably
being alone
not having any friends
i don't give any like like yo
let's just get a bunch of shots of you
looking super lonely
just lean up against that railing just
totally alone why do they have to get
her doing her manscaped routine like
that's so dark i know it's not necessary
you know some ladies got facial hair
it's okay
well that's the that's the [ __ ] up
part of the show it's like
they make it seem like not
like being your natural self is like
hell can't wait to see her here she is
the brand new marsha meddleberg
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
did the [ __ ] like
the [ __ ] like head shake from the
doctors
when she comes down they're like
i am in shock you look out of this world
come with me you believe that this was
from 15 years ago and not like 20 years
in the future yeah feeling right at this
moment in time i'm feeling good what
about your emotional transformation
marcia because you came to us you're so
shy and you're so reserved i
feel
beautiful now i
believe in myself
and nobody can take that away from me yo
pause like how do you feel right now
she's like uh i don't know you guys like
broke my nose
and
filled me up with all this [ __ ] so i
can't really tell what i feel right now
and i'm on a ton of drugs to recover
from all the damage you've done that's
not far from the truth though there's
like this one screenshot i just saw from
the show where like this person's like
you know
wrapped up in bandages from like their
forehead down like you can't even see
their features because it's all like
totally got everything redone and she
was like i'm in so much pain and they're
like it'll be worth it trust me
christ
now i'm gonna ask you to step up to the
curtain
and when you're ready we'll let you see
yourself i'm ready you are ready good
because it's time
off you go
[Music]
yeah i'm just talking because of the
dmca
i just want to see this reveal what are
these crazy angles man
[Music]
no way
oh my god
what if they gave her a big ass beard
oh my god man
and we gave you beard implants
what
and you will
yeah we noticed you were having trouble
getting past the stubble so we uh we
went ahead and
got
hooked you up
now you can grow a full-on biker beard
no problem we got you this br this
beautiful designer wardrobe to go along
with your new look oh my god that's
amazing yeah um 10 children died making
these clothes so
we uh
we hope you understand the cost to make
you beautiful
and we noticed that your kidney kind of
sucked so we replaced it with a new one
where did you get a kidney from don't
don't you worry about that
yeah when we put you under we realized
that one of the valves in your heart
wasn't doing so well
so we had someone knocked off and we did
the first successful heart transplant of
2004.
yeah there's some shitty production
assistant i like how they like keep her
in quarantine and then eventually show
her to him a mirror like you know
like some like like guantanamo tactics
to yeah
get a positive reaction
i just want to look at myself no
not until the finale
imagine in present day she did all that
just to get on tinder for some guy to be
like hit her with an awful one-liner
she's like why did i do any of this
everything's the same
you